more than a thousand firefighters are
battling smoke and massive flames from
the largest of nearly 20 fires burning
in the West the 416 fire in southern
Colorado threatens several communities
and has already burned 32,000 acres it's
one of 17 fires burning from California
to Oklahoma Omar Villafranca is at a
roadblock near the command center in
Durango California Colorado pardon me
Omar good morning good morning as you
can see behind me emergency crews still
have the main highway blocked off to
keep people away from the flames the 416
fire has been burning for about two
weeks now but it's only 18% contained
two major wildfires continue to burn in
Colorado tearing through dry brush amid
severe drought conditions despite the
efforts of more than a thousand
firefighters officials say they have no
idea when they'll get the larger fire
called the 416 under control everybody
who's involved in the suppression effort
they're working in really really extreme
complex terrain hot dry windy with the
carts you know stacked against them most
days more than 2,000 homes have been
evacuated since this fire began on June
1st
hundreds of people were allowed back but
some say the threat of thunderstorms
this weekend is causing them to stay
away Desiree Champlin is choosing to
remain in a tent outside a Red Cross
shelter with her son and 7 month-old
baby we're kind of waiting to see what
this big storm does because we're kind
of worried that with a flash flood this
predicted it could cause a mudslide
firefighters are on the lookout for any
changes in the weather or wind patterns
that could increase the fire threat to
any nearby structures
they're doing an awesome job they're
working hard they're given a hundred and
ten percent to meet the objectives and
most importantly to get no structures
lost no accidents and injuries and
that's a good thing how long did you
guys expect him to be here
we'll be here two weeks at least two
weeks until it's over or contained
containment is a long ways out there is
some good news there are storms in the
forecast but crews are still worried
about lightning which could spark new
fires now Governor John Hickenlooper is
expected to visit the Durango area
trying to get the word out that despite
this fire this tourist area is still
open for business Nora
all right Omar thank you